this week apologies were a common theme
after fallout from headline-grabbing
blunders United Airlines yesterday
repeated its commitment to quote make
this right after growing backlash over a
passenger's violent removal from a--from
a flight and earlier this week White
House press secretary Sean Spicer faced
calls to resign for his comparison of
Syrian President Bashar al-assad with
Adolf Hitler we didn't use chemical
weapons in World War two you know you
had a you know someone who's despicable
as Hitler who didn't even sink to the to
the - using chemical weapons situations
like these call for expertise in the art
of crisis management CBS News
contributor and publican strategist
Frank Luntz joins us from Los Angeles
Frank good morning good morning first of
all let's look at the United situation
from from the actual decision to pull
the man off the plane itself to the
delayed apology from United how does a
accompany of this kind of Sighs make so
many poor decision well you have to
figure out whether this is a
communication problem a judgment problem
an education problem or simply a stupid
decision and in this case it is it looks
like it's all of them yes all of the
above
yeah and I'm waiting to see who actually
loses their job over this the person who
made that decision to remove the
passenger it's clearly not qualified and
capable to work in an airline and
neither is that person's supervisor
second is that now you use the language
that we and I will quote you that we
will make this right that's actually not
what the apology says it says we will
work to make this right and I don't
understand that
because that'll put some distance
between the airline and actually doing
it let me give you a second example I
promise you which is in that apology
should have been my commitment as CEO
and our commitment as United don't make
a promise nobody trusts people who do
that so I think that the airline is
still missing the point that it has to
not only say that it takes
responsibility it has to show it they
should have done that immediately
correct and by the way it's obvious
charlie when when a video is
least it's over and done and the apology
isn't just enough to say hey we got it
wrong it's also has to communicate what
we are going to do in the future to get
this right
it has to communicate I'm gonna make you
whole again you don't want to see this
lawsuit appear at United Airlines so
what do they do to make sure that this
lawsuit you know is seven so they made a
commitment that they're gonna have new
policies by the 30th of April frankly my
suggestion to them would be to allow
that passenger to fly free and United
for the rest of his life that is a
legitimate way to show how deep this
mistake was how embarrassing it was to
that passenger and it says to every
passenger that this company will
sacrifice something in itself to make it
right for every passenger going forward
Frank we have talked about this story
every day this week on this program this
video has been viewed hundreds of
millions of times in China for example
what does corporate America not
understand about social media and viral
video what do they need to learn the
problem is most of these senior
management people don't live on YouTube
they don't live on Twitter someone else
does it for them and that's a mistake
they have to be among the passengers
among their customers to really feel
them and if I were the CEO I frankly
would have gone out and started doing
focus groups I would have gone to every
airport that United flies and I would
have invited passengers to vent their
frustration so you can hear it firsthand
I truly believe that there is a distance
between the senior management and the
people that they wish to serve their
employees their customers and the
communities that they operate in but
that's going to change and every company
needs to hold a crisis management
seminar with the very worst thing that
they could ever think of happening
because I promise you that's what has
happened in this country whatever you
can imagine the actual case will be even
worse Frank shifting quickly to Sean
Spicer situation he apologized for the
comments we played when he said that
Hitler did not use chemical weapons is
is that apology enough well I know that
for some and I'm one of them I lost
significant numbers of my family that
when you hear the word Hitler you
immediately think gas chambers and so
this this
is about the worst mistake that you
possibly can make that said I've watched
him over the last 48 hours and he's
clearly tortured by this and to watch
his response he gets it the problem or
the challenge is that it is the toughest
job on the face of the earth imagine
trying to face 50 people who want to
take you down every day so I give him
credit for going out there but it's
gonna take some time for him to restore
the credibility that he needs crisis
communications Frank Luntz thanks as
always rank thank you